hey everybody in New York City this week
the 100 year old Widow of sports and
civil rights Pioneer Jackie Robinson cut
the ribbon on a new state-of-the-art
Museum dedicated to her late husband
he was 75 years ago in the spring of
1947 that Robinson walked onto Ebbets
Field Brooklyn and into history breaking
baseball's color barrier to become the
first black player in the major leagues
April 15 1947 was an historic day in our
country because America was tremendously
polarized racially Della Britton is the
president and CEO of the Jackie Robinson
Foundation when Jackie stepped out onto
Ebbets Field and on that day it was
momentous and it was something that to
this day is cited as the pivotal moment
in the Civil Rights Movement
thank you
during his 10 years in the majors
Robinson was named an All-Star six years
in a row and played in six World Series
seven years later he was inducted into
the Baseball Hall of Fame but his legacy
and impact extended far off the playing
field he used his baseball celebrity to
push the envelope to bring the issues of
civil rights to bring the issues of
disparity throughout Society to the
Forefront Robinson's life was cut short
when he died of a heart attack in 1972
at the age of 53 but he remains a
revered figure in 1997 his number 42 was
retired from every MLB team and now this
Museum 14 years in the making highlights
include Robinson's game-worn home
uniform his 1947 contract with the
Dodgers for a five thousand dollar
annual salary and honors from baseball
and Beyond including the Congressional
gold medal and the presidential medal of
freedom it's a place to come and learn
about Jackie but then to be inspired to
to go on and and continue his work
this is an incredible Legacy but but I
have to say my first knowledge of Jackie
Robinson came through the foundation
that his widow Rachel Robinson
established which has given out scores
and scores of scholarships to young
people that's a lasting Legacy beyond
the bricks and mortar about time all
right good stuff